a few days before the election i spoke
with
oscar winner sean penn about donald
trump's presidency during a crisis
and he did not hold back
that sounds good shawna you and uh jose
andres penned an op-ed together
calling for the president to embody his
self-reclaimed title
at the beginning of this president at
the beginning of this pandemic as a
wartime
president and you know you asked him to
work with congress to bring americans
financial relief
as we know that hasn't happened at least
in the second
uh portion of the relief that needs to
go to american citizens as someone who's
been on the ground for for many
catastrophes uh
and uh tragedies what are you seeing
that
led what are you seeing in this specific
situation
that led you to write this piece
this is a level of incompetence be it on
a political level or on a human level
that few of us have ever seen that work
in any kind of crisis
this is one of the things that i i i
just don't understand about where we are
as a country where where the those who
support the president
are not able to see that that not only
is it covet
that makes us vulnerable it's virtually
any crisis facing this president and his
administration
will be met with a level of incompetence
that will
cost lives and and then on top of that
to fuel the vitriol uh in ways that are
so
against any kind of kindness of spirit
or spiritual belief or care it's
it's been a level of
political obscenity like i've
never seen before
hi i'm zerlina maxwell thanks for
checking out our channel on youtube
you can see more from zerlina by
clicking any of the videos on this
screen
and make sure you subscribe below to
stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories
thanks for watching